la tunisie face à une nouvelle
recrudescence de kobe de 19
le pays déjà très touché par le manque
de moyens humains et matériels a tranché
pour une nouvelle mise sous cloche total
de quatre régions
la correspondance à tunis de ben hassen
chébili quatre régions placées sous
confinement total et ce pour une semaine
annonce faite hier soir par le
gouvernement suite à la recrudescence de
contamination de ces quatre régions de
ker ans et diana mais j'avais encore à
rouen d'un taux de contamination qui
dépasse les 0 4% alors que les hôpitaux
peine à soigner les cas les plus graves
dans certaines zones du pays ces quatre
régions ont enregistré plus de 400 cas
positifs pour cent mille habitants
au cours de ses 14 derniers jours pour
faire face à l'augmentation rapide des
cas positifs de ces régions des
campagnes régionales de dépistage et des
centres d'isolement pour les cas
positifs seront mises en place des
services de santé et militaires ont été
mobilisés sur la région de kairouan où
les établissements de santé peine à
faire face à l'afflux de nouveaux
malades
un coup dur pour la tunisie qui a levé
la plupart de ces restrictions à la
proche de l'été et de la saison
touristique
malgré un couvre-feu maintenu de 22h à
5h du matin le pays enregistre
actuellement plusieurs dizaines de décès
plus de deux mille nouveaux cas
confirmés par jour pour une population
qui ne dépasse pas les 12 millions
d'habitants